the Joe Rogan experience but here's an
interesting cat man yes yes a bunch of
things rolled up into one because he's a
he's a legitimate Catholic like yeah
really Catholic yeah despite all the
scandals and kid fuckin and all the
craziness and then on top of that he's
this character but now he's not the
character anymore no now he's like a guy
who's not totally playing the character
but the character comes in and out like
little shadows yes it does it's like
what are you what's your real thoughts
on things cuz I know you as Colbert yeah
I know you from The Colbert Report this
hilarious fake Republican guy yeah and
now I'm seeing him I'm not sure what's
going on here man yeah I mean he's well
and when you're put when you're in late
night you know I play a character on my
show too
that's like a heightened version of
myself that's developed it's like a very
extra nerdy it's almost like me as
pee-wee Herman a little bit like it's
it's uh towards me as my younger self
it's like very socially awkward I'm a
less re up there you know yeah and it's
different than what I do on stage and
you know I can only imagine even though
he's still he's like his big thing for
late night was like I'm gonna be myself
I'm not the character anymore you still
build a little bit of a character for
yourself you know yeah well also with
him it's like that's what brought him to
the dance yeah the reason why you're
there is like what what kind of meetings
that they have with him yeah like what
are we gonna do here we're gonna hire
this straight Colbert I heard him say
once he only said this in one interview
but he was like we're basically creating
a new character for late-night and so he
had the same writers from from The
Colbert Report and so he was like we're
sort of like creating a new character
how does this character work but I gotta
say the old show I mean he's he's great
the old show was probably the best
performance ever made by a single
late-night comic because the way that
heat when I watch it now if I go back
and watch clips I'm like the way he
would do like three or four fast little
turns you know you know single line
where it would like mean one thing that
could be some subtext and he would slip
around and he would do it like it was
like watching like a figure skater do
triple axels you know like watching him
do that it was it was really impressive
I'd like the guy don't get me wrong but
I like him more on The Colbert Report
and I like him as a late-night talk show
host but I'd agree I think that's also
my prejudice against that format I'm
like you guys just saw what Jack Paar
did and kept going totally it's the same
goddamn thing but I understand why he
couldn't do the coal but he did that
show for like ten years
you know like you can't you can't do
there was a limited thing for him you
know like he had that character and so
he could only do what was in the box
that character and so he's looking to do
more and and I get it I also feel like
man that Colbert Report is more
interesting than the late-night show to
me as a comic and as a comedy writing
fan well sure because the late-night
shows her just promotion shows that's
all they are all they are is hey Adam I
hear you have a book out hey Mike tell
us about your new show here's our ten
minutes of comedy before that and then
we do that that's like it's it's
basically like a version of a commercial
and the and the nightly thing is a
prison you know because you can only
talk about what happened that day
so the smartest thing that you know john
oliver right he was up for the daily
show he wanted to do the daily show he
was Jon Stewart's pick for the daily
show they said this in the oral history
book of The Daily Show and then Comedy
Central didn't close the deal with
Oliver and HBO came and said you want to
do a show instead you know and Jon
Stewart was like all right go with God
that's what Jon Oliver did instead so
we're living in that alternate reality
from John Oliver hosting The Daily Show
right
and so the smartest thing Oliver did was
do weekly and not daily because it lets
him go wider right if he was doing daily
he would have to just talk about what
happened that day you don't have that
much you don't guess what you can't have
as much of a complete thought in 24
hours or in realistically the six hours
you have between when you show up and
when you tape the show right you can't
say as much you it's it's harder and so
being on that you know weekly schedule
and he's only doing thirtysomething
shows a year right because they have
hiatuses that's what allows them to have
those big long complete thoughts that
everyone likes so much yes is ransom
yeah intelligent takes these issues in
pointing out Apocrypha yeah great our
show it takes us we it takes us like
three or four months to write an episode
like we're writing 16 at once but like
you know that's how long we have to
think about it and so we're able to take
twists and turns you know we we go into
it thinking this is going to be our
angle and then we're diving into the
research we have a wonderful research
staff and they say actually
is the more interesting part of the
story and then we are have the time to
go chase it that way instead right
whereas if we were on a daily schedule
oh shit well we don't have time to pivot
because we got a show to make right you
ever feel good time constraints like in
terms of like the subject matter the
subject matter is like very very
involved yeah I mean we try to do the
most difficult topics we can't you know
we don't hold back from anything but the
only constraint that we have is that the
show we've got 21 minutes and then in
but we've got commercials so we can only
talk about some four six minutes before
we have to move on right and so that's
the that's the only limitation that we
have
[Applause]